all right and if you'll all bear with us
for a moment while i get our live stream
started
for
our
linkedin live audience it will take me a
moment
apologize for the delay
all right
i believe we are now streaming on
linkedin live as well
and so i will begin the presentation my
name is stuart creek by the way and i am
a marketing manager
here simply learn
and i'm here today with nick polikovsky
who is a senior editor of dice insights
i'm going to be talking about
what he sees in the market
the top-tier tech companies
so-called main companies are looking for
in their tech hires
so
let you know how to participate in the
webinar if you're
in the uh live web ex event please
put your questions for nick into the q a
panel and i'll be uh tracking those and
and we'll get to those at the q and a
part of the
webinar
uh you can also put a chat for all
panelists if you're watching on live
streaming on youtube or linkedin you can
put your questions into the comments so
we have folks who will relay those to us
and
we're also going to ask you a couple of
questions along the way
and the first one
is a two-part question
which is
how much work experience do you have
this is to give us a feeling for who's
in our audience
and also we're doing a check-in to see
how people are doing we've been
experiencing
strange times in the last two and a half
years so
i'd like to see people how people are
holding up to
lockdowns coming and going and surges
rising and falling and
new viruses springing up
so
i'll give you another 15 seconds or so
to
check in on that
and
five seconds
i'll share the poll result
and
the we have a
fairly even distribution
of folks in the audience about a third
are still in school
but as far as the other levels of
experience it
runs fairly evenly
about a third of folks in fact have more
than five years experience up in the
marketplace
and as far as our check-in it's good to
see that um
nearly everybody is doing okay or doing
um
better than okay so
we hope that what you have to share with
us will help improve the outlook for the
people in that third category
and
with that
just give you a quick introduction
but you can talk more about yourself
here um
nick kolakowski as i mentioned is the
senior editor of dice insights the
online publication of the career website
and platform dice which is the premier
career platform for technical careers
and
he's written extensively including a
novel so
we're very pleased to have him here and
have him share his insights into the
industry welcome nick thank you and
thanks everybody i'm really happy to be
here um i am
very impressed with the spread of
experience on this call today and i
think that we are going to have a really
good conversation um
so just to start it off in general i
know that the topic of discussion day
obviously is to focus on
kind of the the hiring practices and the
preparation for top-tier
fang companies or you know given how
facebook has changed its name to meta
and so on the acronym seems to change on
an almost daily basis um so it could be
fang it could be mang it could be i've
seen a lot of different permutations as
companies cycle through so but
we all know what we're talking about
here which is essentially companies like
meta alphabet netflix microsoft et
cetera huge companies that are making
a massive difference in how
everyone billions literally billions of
people are using their technology every
day whether it's for productivity
whether it's for fun whether it's for
social networking or what have you these
companies are at the forefront of it and
so getting a job there is obviously
extremely exciting um for two reasons
and the first is that
even though you're part of a massive
team usually
the overall team is usually making
enormous progress both in terms of the
final product whatever that might be
whether it's you know the new better
microsoft word or
a really cool streaming platform but a
lot of these teams are also making
significant differences in terms of the
back end tools in terms of technology
itself so for example
if you're working at google you might be
working on something like google docs or
search or whatever but you also might
have the opportunity to
create a language like golang or
kind of any sort of technical tool that
millions of developers and technologists
around the world will end up using and
that's an enormous opportunity to make a
real difference to your peers so
these companies offer a number of
exciting opportunities but competition
for them or to get slots as you might
understand is extremely tough um
obviously everybody not everybody but
obviously millions of people want to
work at google they want to work at
microsoft they want to work at
meta and so on and so competition is
fierce
and obviously you're going to be asking
yourself kind of what are what what is
first what is the typical hiring
procedure at these companies and then
how can you tailor your experience and
skills and so on to
put yourself in the most optimal
position to land a job at these firms um
and so i the probably the best way to
approach it is to discuss the typical
hiring procedure at these companies um
unfortunately they all tend to roughly
align with each other um
procedures are different you know for
example the the hiring ramp at amazon is
necessarily different than what you will
find at google or microsoft or so on but
all generally tend to follow kind of i
guess the rough same general framework
and the framework is this
you know
you
these companies all have hiring portals
so you can go online
and submit your application and so on or
there's often recruiters and hiring
managers who are scouring
all sorts of channels and venues whether
they're looking on linkedin whether they
are just kind of lurking around github
wherever they are there's a lot of
recruiters out there who will
if they see you online kind of ping you
for
you know to see if you're potentially
interested in the job and so
the first step before you even engage in
any sort of hiring conversation with any
company and this isn't just kind of a
fang issue this is also literally any
company in the technology industry
um is to make sure that kind of all of
your online profiles and all of your
online materials and so on are arranged
in an optimal way and what i mean by
that is
you know for example if you have a repos
on github making sure that those repos
are updated and that the links those
repos are
posted on wherever you set your digital
hat whether that's a personal website
whether that's some sort of professional
social profile
make sure that your coding work is first
and foremost um
if you're not a developer or an engineer
or if you are but if you're in another
kind of branch of technology whether
you're a data analyst whether you're a
ui ux designer whatever your particular
track is
having a website that displays your
portfolio your previous projects and so
on is always useful
because one of the key things about
having a personal website or portfolio
or something like that is that as you
are designing your online materials for
application as you are submitting your
resume and so on
leaving that link gives recruiters and
hiring managers a very easy way to click
view your work kind of get an idea of
the things that interest you and so on
they'll also get a sense of your passion
because you put your personal projects
up there it shows that you are engaged
with technology on
an emotional and a passionate level and
that's extremely appealing to companies
they're looking for to hire because they
want people who are you know engaged to
the very fiber of their being
so
you clean up your online profiles and so
on you have your portfolio of work
it's also always helpful to do a check
um
sometimes people post things on social
media that
you know aren't necessarily kind of the
most appropriate so you know sometimes
before you're going out on a job hunt
some technologists like to
scrub and make sure you know there's
there's no photos of them drinking from
a keg or anything like that that they
feel might potentially put them in a not
so great light um but that's sort of
beside issues so
once you have your online profile
set the way that you want it um
and you're ready for the job hunt and
you're ready to engage
you will either apply yourself because
you see an interesting job on a job
marketplace like linkedin or dice or
some place like that or else you are
approached by a recruiter at that point
you're generally locked onto an
application track that like i said
generally follows the same framework no
matter what company it is um and large
companies tend to emulate each other so
for example if google introduces a new
hiring practice you can be assured that
microsoft amazon netflix and so on will
begin to
mirror that practice to a certain extent
and if one of these companies takes a
particular element out of out of
commission they will also take it out of
commission
for example for a long time if you want
a job at google you had to get really
good at brain teasers like for example
how many tennis balls will fill a 747
was a question that they were using 15
years ago or
why are manhole covers round
and then you saw other companies like
microsoft and so on
picking that up you know and sort of
emulating that kind of thing and that
was you know it showed that you were
good at puzzles and so on and showed
that you could create think creatively
around problems but it wasn't
necessarily
the best way for companies to evaluate
all of your skills and so google
eliminates brain teasers and other large
companies generally don't follow suit
what companies do do
is you generally the first round is a
phoner which in this modern day and age
means you are on a video call the video
call is generally with a recruiter
um and then there's also generally a
technical call which means that you are
on the phone with
a hiring manager an engineer or even a
group of engineers who will ask you more
technically minded questions um
the key to phoners
is that you it's you have to kind of
regard it as the first tranche you have
to regard it as the recruiter and the
hiring managers and the engineers and so
on are just evaluating that you have the
skills in the advertised position so for
example
if you're applying for a job as a python
developer or a data analyst
that initial phoner is to ensure that
you have a grasp of the language you
know or you have a grasp of the tools
involved or that you have kind of the
conceptual framework necessary to
actually do the job um
there will often be
the testing component will often involve
questions that you know you will answer
on a shared screen and show your work
kind of something along those lines
and then if you pass that particular
test then the companies tend to diverge
from that point you may be asked to do
several technical rounds like for
example netflix is infamous for
subjecting its job candidates to
multiple brands to ensure that you have
firm mastery of whatever technical
skills are involved in the job
amazon as well amazon for example often
makes job candidates go through
a debugging session that you will go
through
an app building session they they will
subject you usually to kind of multiple
tests to ensure that you can sort of
think your way through a project
and then if you get past those technical
tests you will often be called in for an
in-person interview now during the
pandemic obviously everything tended to
be done from video screens and people
were working remotely
but now that offices are opening back up
and so on there's there's a renewed
emphasis on in-person interviews and so
on so you can expect to
come into an office
not necessarily in silicon valley
obviously but many of these companies
have offices all over the place and then
you'll go through multiple rounds with
multiple teams um these interviews also
require quite a bit of endurance because
they will take
six or seven hours you will meet with
three or four teams you will be
absolutely a hundred and ten percent
exhausted by the time you get to the
very end um
they will also involve a lot of kind of
technical things you might have to do
the dreaded whiteboard test you might
have to do the equally dreaded
pair programming test um
but whatever it is it will be sort of
another round of testing your technical
aptitude
and so when you're preparing for
all of these rounds when you aspire to
work for a fang company there is
a couple of things that you can do in
order to ensure that your technical
proficiency is where it needs to be in
order to meet these particular
challenges um if you're looking for
resources online that can help you
prepare
lead code is usually what i recommend
people head to first
let's say you're applying for a job at
google involving java and the ultimate
goal is to
work with android um there's a lot of
segmentation on
fleet code that you know will show walk
you through java and
android and so on um
and you know will allow you to kind of
it won't necessarily tell you what
they'll actually ask but it'll sort of
boost your proficiency and
re-familiarize you with key concepts
before you head into
the interview itself um
in addition
at the fang companies but also at
smaller companies as well
there is
how do i put this um lots of recruiters
and hiring managers will also
sometimes actually take questions from
lead code for the initial phone screener
and for kind of the early round
interviews and then apply them to the
interview process itself so a lot of
technologists and developers and
software engineers and so on
will
encounter the same questions that they
saw on lead code
and so that that's also something to
keep in mind as well that's generally
what we recommend that people do in
order to kind of get that sort of base
level proficiency um
but the thing as well is the thing to
remember with the sort of these
technical tiers of these interviews is
that as you are progressing through it
if you encounter a super technical
question that you
think you can't answer for whatever
reason
the key is always to walk through the
problem as far as you can even if you
don't know the answer because what
recruiters and hiring managers and
engineers and so on
are all aiming for is to see that you
can think your way through a problem
even if you can't get to the ultimate
solution they want to know that you are
an analytical thinker that you are a
problem solver that you can apply a
certain degree of creativity to the
problems
you know at hand um
and so even if you don't sort of land on
a definitive solution whenever you get
to a technical question you should work
it as much as you can
while explaining your work as you go to
show that you're ideating in the correct
way when it comes to
these issues um
the other important thing
and people tend to focus so much on the
technical side of things that sometimes
they forget this at their peril is the
soft skills side of things and this
applies not only to technical roles but
also the non-technical roles in fact
with non-technical roles whether it's
marketing or management or something
like that it's even more important that
you emphasize
your soft skills which means
your ability to communicate your ability
to empathize your ability to work
effectively in teams um positivity is
always a huge component of this
because
the recruiters and the hiring managers
and the engineers and so on are all
evaluating whether you have the capacity
to work effectively with teams i mean
like i said at the beginning of this
presentation especially as you get to
bigger companies
you're not working solo i mean if you
look at a company like apple for example
some of these teams that work on things
like the iphone like even the marketing
team will be 200 or 300 people or even
more
and and if you can't work effectively
with
people all through that strata then
you're potentially in trouble so
recruiters and hiring managers and even
the engineers will ask you
often
for example how you dealt with
challenges as a team in your previous
positions they will ask how you problem
solved effectively with other people in
collaboration they will ask how you
overcame a mistake or difficulty that
set a project back they just they want
to get a sense that you're flexible and
empathetic and that you're able to
engage with others
there was a very illuminating
interview that blind which is a great
website that anonymously
yeah anonymously surveys technologists
about a range of issues
um asked of a google executive i think
it was a couple of weeks ago go to i
think it's teamblind.com and i think
it's it's probably still on the front of
their site but
this google executive who had risen up
from being an engineer to being a higher
up manager
sort of emphasized that the way that you
climb in a company like google to
senior management whether you're in a
non-technical role like marketing or a
technical role
isn't so much having kind of you know
concrete programming skills or something
like that
the focus was much more on being able to
collaborate um
and being able to work effectively in a
team and sort of subsume your own goals
almost for the the goals of the
collective as he put it there's there's
no such thing as brilliant jerks in when
it comes to these giant companies i mean
sure there are
brilliant developers who might be a
little bit abrasive who can make big
moves and help move a project forward
and so on but
longevity and sustainability at these
companies usually hinges on your ability
to get along and work effectively with
others and listen to people have empathy
for their concerns and so on so that's
as big a deal in a lot of ways as your
technical skills no matter what role
you're potentially applying for um
i will take a brief breath uh does
anybody have any questions or anything i
can address before we continue to move
on um
i will scan to this
yeah i mean i'm looking at a number of
the things by the way you mentioned lead
code i did
and what was the other uh
url or the the site that you mentioned
for the
article from the google executive oh
yeah so team blind um
let me let me double check that url
before i accidentally send something out
to the collective but team blind is
a site where as i said technology
workers can anonymously post um
their various issues and so on and a lot
of the time
uh it's it's people venting you know and
and although the participants on the
website are verified as working for
these large fang companies sometimes
it's people just wanting to express that
they have issues with the cafeteria food
that week or something like that
um their blog however where they curate
a lot of the content and sort of conduct
polls on a regular basis of fang
companies is enormously valuable for
anybody who is applying for a position
at these companies because
it gives you a
insight into internal morale it gives
you insight into pay scales when they
run those sorts of surveys and so on so
i highly recommend that everybody check
it out to get kind of a cultural feel
for these companies as you're
considering applying for them
all right and that's team blind is that
right correct and the blog portion of it
is um
i can even drop that in the chat that
would be great
yes right
so i highly recommend this in a dice we
often because part of what i do at
dice.com is we monitor the
culture and sentiment of
these various companies um we find it a
pretty invaluable resource
and somebody asked
what's your opinion are you familiar
with hacker rank as opposed to leak code
yes hacker rank is another one that i
should have mentioned in conjunction
with leeco but it very much is another
place that you can that you can check to
kind of as you're doing prep um
to get the information that you need
reddit as well can also potentially be
helpful there are subreddits devoted to
programming cs questions cs career
questions
those various subreddits are often the
good thing about it is that it's usually
organized by topics so for example if
you're applying to
you know software engineering role at a
company and you're not 100 sure
you know if you're
have the right idea about the interview
questions or so on if you go to this
technically minded subreddits you can
often ask the question and get good
answers from people who are very solid
um
i've conducted a number of amas on
technical reddits and the thing that
i've generally found is that everybody
who participates in those reddits
is very serious
you're not going to get a lot of sort of
trolls you're not going to get a lot of
people who don't know what they're
talking about so if you're willing to
create a reddit account and engage in
the conversation it takes a little bit
of digging to find the subreddits that
work for you especially if you're aiming
at a more
sort of esoteric branch of text but it's
it's definitely worth
participating in that community
um and before we go on just want to make
a note somebody asked we get a recording
of this session yet if you're
on the live session here um
uh you've been registered we'll be
sending a follow-up email with a link to
this recording so you'll be able to
review what what nick has been talking
about um
so uh did you want to go on and and of
course that's your next topic i will um
so and and thank you somebody in the
comments actually asked this question
but this was this was the next thing
that i was going to talk about which is
do i think participating in hackathons
and open source projects is helpful for
technical roles and the answer to that
is unabashed yes now
the thing about open source projects as
i mentioned at the beginning of the
presentation
is that
they're useful in a number of ways first
just as in terms of your career outside
of applying to any specific fang company
participating open source project boosts
your skills
it introduces you to really interesting
problems to solve and in fact because so
many companies depend on open source
code
problems that you solve are working on
open source projects will boost your
aptitude when it comes time to applying
for jobs
and so finding open source projects that
you are interested in and then
participating in them and you know
adding to their repos you know
doing whatever sort of it needs to
whatever needs to be done for those
projects is immensely valuable in pretty
much any sort of technical role and then
in addition to that once you've built up
a sort of
massive code once you have a lot of
demonstrable experience in working on
open source projects two things happen
first thing is that you can use it in
your portfolio as i mentioned at the
beginning of this but then the other
thing too is that a lot of recruiters
and hiring managers and so on
are also participating in open source
projects i mean a lot of the people at
these companies continue to do these
sorts of things for fun and so
you're building these connections with
them and then it might be out of the
blue it might be a connection that you
foster talking through problems with
people but you might get a job offer
through sort of demonstrating your
ability in
within these projects
hackathons um
are also really valuable especially ones
that are hosted by certain companies
because obviously those companies are
doing it to sort of get a feel for
talent hackathons there was a period
where hackathons are all over the place
five years ago like every every it seems
like that has cooled a little bit but
nonetheless they still remain sort of
intensely valuable
the other question here that's really
interesting and i want to cover it
because here at dice
we churn through massive amounts of
information related to salaries and
compensation and things like that so
somebody is asking
you know what are the top paid tech jobs
for 2022 um that's a really excellent
question i'm sure everyone here is
intensely interested in it um it's
actually a really complicated question i
can't give you a flat answer and say
python developer or ai researcher or
anything like that
a couple of things need to be mentioned
so first of all fang companies tend to
obviously pay the highest salaries in
the industry
netflix in particular pays
easily the most of any company out there
and the reason that netflix does that is
because
there's culturally they expect every
engineer and even the non-technical
people who show up the company to
deliver
basically you've heard the myth of the
10x engineer the super engineer who
delivers the equivalent of 10 people's
worth of work netflix expects the 100x
engineer they expect people to come in
who make seismic strategic differences
who are absolute geniuses who
come in every day and move the needle
substantially and if you don't move the
needle substantially they you were given
a nice severance package and politely
ushered out the door so
in exchange for that
it's not uncommon to see netflix
salaries for mid-level engineers in the
300 000 range once you include salary
and
compensation through stock and so on
other companies follow sort of a similar
patterning for example
at pretty much every single fang company
once you even even at the entry level
but even after you ascend
beyond the entry level um in terms of
engineering in terms of product
management and so on
you can expect a six figure salary
that six figure salary comes with stock
options which usually vest on a five
year schedule
depending on the company you can also
expect a bonus some companies give much
larger bonuses than others for example
microsoft google
et cetera tend to be bonus happy but
when you look at oracle or sap some of
these enterprise giants they tend not to
kind of fall into the same category um
but fang overall is lucrative which is
why
obviously companies compete for it um
when it comes to other salary when it
comes to salaries in the tech industry
in general there are a number of factors
that go into it the first is geography
if you live in a what we call a
traditional tech hub like silicon valley
new york city boston and so on you can
generally expect a higher salary and
that's because the companies in those
zones
factor in a higher cost of living and
the companies that exist in those zones
tend to be larger tech companies or
really well-funded startups that realize
that they're competing against a lot of
talent
locally and so therefore willing to
pay what they need to pay in order to
secure that talent
for a long time if you live in a place
outside of those traditional tech hubs
first you know kansas city phoenix
basically any city that's not sort of
instantly synonymous with tech
generally you had to expect to get a
lower salary even if your skills were
sort of on the level with people at the
large tech companies and places like san
francisco however that's changing and
it's largely due to the rise of remote
work
something that we and other publications
and websites and companies have seen is
that
the so-called geography gap that
persisted for a long time where there
was uneven salaries between
technologists working in different
cities has started to level out
and that's because a lot of these
companies are now open to remote talent
but if you're open to remote talent it
means you need to pay your people
in the same sort of tier of salary
whether they are working in san
francisco whether they're working in l.a
or whether they're working in rural
montana or someplace like that so
the salaries aren't completely level and
some companies are deliberately
adjusting their salaries so that people
outside of high cost of living areas are
paid less but overall we're seeing sort
of this this equalization develop in
salaries um
and then obviously the other factor that
is that is a major play is experience
now on this particular webinar we have
people who have a broad range of
experience we have people who have been
in the industry for over five years we
have people who are just starting out
the more experience that you build the
more that your salary will climb um
there's an asterisk to that however
and the asterisk is a simple one it's
that
tech evolves so rapidly that you need to
sort of keep your skills continually up
to date
you can't you know every time if you
work in a particular set of programming
languages every time those programming
languages have another iteration or an
evolution you need to stay on top of it
you need to stay on top of
the data science tools or the machine
learning tools or the frameworks or
whatever is sort of involved in your
specialization
because that is the key to sort of
unlocking the higher salary tiers
the other thing that comes into play
with experience is certifications now
some professions such as cyber security
are very intense about your
certifications you can't get certain job
you know certifications pop up as a
requirement for particular jobs um
and generally that's fine it just means
that you have to recognize which ones
you need whether that's project
management whether it's a comptia cyber
security certification whatever it is
you know what you need to get and so you
get it um
but not all technology jobs are the same
way when it comes to certifications
there are lots of companies that
sort of want you to demonstrate that you
have the experience and the aptitude and
they care less about certification so
long as you can demonstrate that you
have that particular strength
so that's sort of the other key thing as
well um
if you don't feel for example as a
developer that you need a certification
to land a particular job that's totally
fine you don't need to do that but you
definitely need to demonstrate that in
your two years five years ten years
however long you've been in the industry
that you've mastered all the skills
necessary and that you are kind of
completely up to date on everything so
experience is a really important factor
in it but that's also with caveats um
the other interesting thing is that this
applies to fang companies this applies
to smaller companies and so on but
there are lots of technologies out there
who don't necessarily want to optimize
their salary if they can get other sort
of concessions and benefits uh for
example we've seen this rise of flexible
and remote work as part of the pandemic
but now that
companies are opening their offices back
again
there's now been this drive to
people want remote they want remote work
they want hybrid work they want a
flexible schedule and things like that
and many of them are actually willing to
take pay cuts to get it not all of them
some people insist that the work i can
do at home is the same at the office
therefore i should be paid the same no
matter where i'm working from but other
people have been demonstrating more of a
willingness to take some sort of salary
cut in exchange for
remote work so that's another factor as
well
in terms of skills that pay the most
outside of jobs
popular programming languages such as
java python especially
sql which means that you have an
aptitude for working with data and so on
are all
jobs that pay quite a bit i mean if you
master popular skills there's lots of
opportunities out there there's lots of
companies competing for your talents
obviously
we've also seen an increase in how much
people are paid for
artificial intelligence and machine
learning work so that means mastering
tensorflow
it means knowing how to operate evolving
models and things like that um
once you've if once you've sort of
mastered ai skills and you have done
research and you are sort of a known
quantity you are a rare enough candidate
that companies will pay enormous amounts
of money i remember a few years ago i
went to a conference with some
executives from ibm who said that they
paid
some of their ai researchers the
equivalent of nfl quarterbacks it's
quite a bit of money
and so
it's good news because
mastering popular skills will get you
paid a lot of money but also mastering
the esoteric in-demand skills the next
generation skills will also pay you a
lot of money as well um
so yeah that's that's that's my horribly
lengthy answer to payment it comes down
to where you work comes down to your
experience which includes certifications
and so on it includes the size of the
company you work for where fang and
well-monetized companies are generally
paying more than
your sort of smaller smaller companies
so
let me see if i can tackle another
question um
yeah um
as you were talking about the the ideas
of certification qualification do you
kashif has a question about
whether a developer
needs to have a range of
languages uh
different
skill sets
yeah or do you do you get to be a
specialist in one
so that's that's a really excellent
question um and it really depends on the
company so i would say that
it's generally generally when you are
working on
most technology products you will need
to have mastery of a handful of things
and then you will need familiarity with
others so for example let's say that you
want to work at apple and let's say you
want to work on
something involving the app store so
you will need to know objective-c which
is apple's long-time programming
languages i think it was it started up
in 1985 and up until 2014
it was the primary language that people
use to develop apps and so on and so
tons of legacy code is written in it and
you still need familiarity with it in
addition to that you also need to master
swift which is apple's new programming
language they rolled out
swift started out very stripped down but
it's actually been bulking up on
features with every new iteration over
the past several years and so now it's
become much more of a full-fledged
programming language so you'd need to
know those two
you'd need to know sql
you'd need to know kind of the
principles of data and database
management because all these apps on the
back end feed things back to
whatever database you know whether it's
customer related or
you know gaming related anything like
that um you need to know the principles
of project management just because like
i said i mean a lot of these companies
put an emphasis on working in teams and
so the principles of agile the
principles of working in a scrum
and sprints you know and then sort of
prioritizing what needs to be done in
terms of tasks and then integrating
those assassins in your workflow
you can definitely get by i feel if
you're a super specialist in one or two
particular skills or languages but
the more well-rounded you are the more
at least
at least if you have
a familiarity with a variety of skills
then your marketability will increase
exponentially from that point because
you can slot into a number of jobs one
of the interesting things that
so we have a platform called mc burning
glass which actually just rebranded
itself as lightcast but it allows us to
look at and analyze millions upon
millions of job postings from across the
country almost in real time churn that
data by geography sorted by valued
skills and so on and also sorted by
companies and one of the things that we
saw that was interesting at companies
was that you would expect
a company to only want to hire people
that utilizes tech stack so for example
at google you would all you would think
that java kotlin
the sk golang the skills involved in
google would be all they would hire for
but the thing that we found was
interesting is that
the number of
open jobs for swift
and for languages that weren't in google
stack was actually enormous and the same
at apple as well at apple you know
there's all sorts of languages that you
wouldn't think apple would use but
they're hiring in droves for and the
reason for that is that
these companies are the fan companies
are obviously working on multiple
platforms and they need people who have
the aptitude to work on multiple
platforms or at least the familiarity
with it
um and also
these companies are thinking towards the
future and they're they're sort of
future proofing things um
for example microsoft a number of years
ago was trying to push the entire
industry towards silverlight as this
platform for streaming video and so on
and netflix went in on it all these
other companies went on and then and
then microsoft veered and decided to
embrace like another
language and so everyone who had spent
all this time learning silverlight ended
up being in a bad way and having to
reverse and learn something else really
quickly the more languages and things
you master in the more you can adapt to
the rapid pivots in the technology
industry you know if someone at google
wakes up one day and decides that
they're going to suddenly embrace
another language you'll be prepared for
it so
mastering one is fine but it's always
much better to
me try to at least have familiarity with
all the popular ones out there um
the analysis that we've gone from stack
overflow which is another website i hope
everyone on this call is familiar with
shows that python java javascript c
um are generally the ones that you
should know like just kind of in general
like almost every company works with
them to some degree
the big tech also sql is is something
that pops up consistently as one of the
top pain and also one of the most
ubiquitous
languages given how every company out
there kind of works with databases and
everything else um
once you have those in a few specialized
skills you're you're generally in good
shape
right
we have a couple of questions by the way
that came in from the uh youtube
audience
um
and one of them
has
is generalized to other questions from
our from our
webex audience
how do you get into tech when you come
in from a different industry the youtube
chat
asks about finance for example as a
background but
how do you get into tech if you're
coming in from a
non-tech background that's a wonderful
question and you do indeed see a lot of
people who are coming in from non-tech
backgrounds in the tech because i mean
it's it's
it's not just the money i mean tech is
also fun to work with i mean you can
potentially
do enormous things that you know impact
suddenly your app is being used by a
billion people it's a very exciting
thing so
if you want to rapidly get into
tech there are a couple of different
avenues you can pursue even if you don't
have a formal background in tech a lot
of people decide to go for coding boot
camps for those who are unfamiliar with
at a coding bootcamp is a very intensive
and often very expensive course where
you
work full-time for a number of weeks it
depends on the boot camp some are eight
weeks some are up to 16 weeks and you
learn something very specific whether
it's front end web development a
particular programming language or
something like that but the goal is to
slam you through and when you come out
the other side you are ready for
employment um
one thing that we have found analyzing
data and this has been backed up by
other companies data regarding coding
boot camps and so on is that
boot camps
in terms of the salary you walk out the
door with and so on like they will
leverage you into a tech job
you have to be careful though because
some boot camps say that they will
guarantee you a job and that's not
necessarily the case you have to sort of
level set and be prepared for like a
hard job hunt you might not get
something immediately it might take you
a while um
but coding boot camps are generally an
okay way to quickly pivot to technology
if you have a longer time horizon
i.e you know tech is a career you're
thinking of jumping to in the next two
or three years as opposed to by this
time next year
um the best thing to do is start by self
learning um and that allows you to do a
couple of different things it lets you
decide i mean the technology industry is
so huge it allows you to decide what
technology you even want to pursue are
you interested in cyber security are you
interested in mobile app development et
cetera so spending some time in
researching and figuring out like what
appeals to you on a visceral level is
key before you decide to make this big
jump into tech because the last thing
you want to do is do something
impulsively and find yourself on a track
you don't you don't feel with your whole
heart
um
and then once you're sort of on that
track um the things that i mentioned
previously in terms of lead code in
terms of reddit in terms of stack
overflow in terms of github
all these various platforms have
ecosystems that allow you to kind of get
a better sense of what you want to
participate in data analytics python
development anything like that
and then if you're uh if you're a
self-starter
there are lots of websites and
documentation out there including
youtube videos for the people who are
watching on youtube that will allow you
to learn quickly um
once you sort of if you're taking this
self-learning approach once you've
started learning the way that you
demonstrate that learning to recruiters
hiring managers and so on is
develop those personal projects which we
talked about is useful whether you're
you know in tech from the beginning and
sort of developing on that track or
whether this is a mid-career pivot for
you
um and especially for people who are
doing the mid-career pivot the personal
projects show that you have a passion
and a familiarity and this is something
you really want to participate in
so then you you have that and then once
you have a certain number of personal
projects once you potentially have taken
some training courses and or bootcampers
on then you can probably feel confident
in applying for entry-level jobs and
whatever interests you um
but it's not i mean there's lots of
people who pivot at all stages of their
careers to tech and they're people
within tech who pivot to a completely
different branch of tech which is
essentially the same thing when you
think that you're learning a completely
different set of skills so it's it's
it's a little intimidating and scary but
millions of people do it and so it's
it's definitely something that you can
do no matter what your career position
or aptitude at the moment
and
related to that uh
just a couple of things about uh simply
learn by the way we
do coding boot camps that are
different
qualitatively than the other ones that
you describe because we
do them in a completely online format so
it's not like you have to
take two weeks off your job and do the
boot camp so it's a different thing but
um they emphasize learning by doing and
developing projects that you can then
show off in your portfolio but the the
other thing i wanted to mention is we
have a number of free resources on
our site so the advice about self
learning um is great you can come to uh
simply learn website in
and find a lot of
self learning resources that are
available no no cost and let you
pick up skills and a lot of different
aspects of technology like you said nick
you can
people can
look at different things try them out
and see which ones resonate with them so
um
see we have
people asking about employment gaps
and time off and
do you have advice for people on how to
say you know if i've been out of the
workforce
been raising children or i've you know
taken a break for some other reason
uh how to get back in into the tech
workforce yeah that's a really fantastic
question and if you're thinking of
re-entering the workforce right now it's
actually a really good moment to do so
so in july the tech unemployment rate
was 1.7 down from 1.8 percent and that
is
significantly below the national
unemployment rate which i believe off
the top my head is 3.8
um but don't quote me on the the
national rate on just the tech rate is
the one that i have memorized um
so and and
when you take that this is all from the
bureau of labor statistics which does
kind of a monthly analysis of technology
jobs and so on and if you take that one
step down
every single industry not just sort of
the tech industry itself and fangs and
so on but you know everything from
manufacturing to retail and so on are
all on the hunt for technologists
because every company sees itself as a
technology company they need websites
built they need databases managed they
need everyone is migrating to the cloud
to answer one of the questions in the
the sidebar here and so people who have
aptitude with aws and so on can secure
very high paying jobs but what that
means is there's an extraordinary amount
of demand right now for technologists
and if you're just re-entering the
workforce and you have a gap however
many
months or years that might be
this is this is a really excellent time
to jump in because companies need your
skills
now
if you have a gap there there's there's
two things you sort of need to keep
aware of and the first is that
companies
you need to the skills for the job
you're applying for you do you need to
have those mastered so
you're coming back in
the recruiter the hiring manager are
seeing that gap you know and lots and
lots and lots of people have gaps so
it's not it's it's something obviously a
lot of people are concerned about but
it's not something to lose sleep over
but you will be tested and so all the
technical
interviews that i mentioned at the
beginning of this the phone or technical
interview the the you know the shared
whiteboard you know or you know kind of
coding homework or whatever
you need to demonstrate that you have
all those concepts down and that will
assure the hiring manager and the
recruiter that you know you might have
taken a gap but you still have the
necessary skills um
the other thing as well is if during
your gap you did anything personal
project wise if you contributed to repos
on github if you
built an app for fun even if you tutored
people in python on the side just you
know as a volunteer or something like
that literally anything you can do to
say like during this gap i kept my
skills up today and i continue to
participate in some way in this
technology
is absolutely invaluable and i think
recruiters and hiring managers realize
that hey people you know life happens
and there's all sorts of things that
lead you to step away but if you
maintained your skills and kept them up
today and you maintain that passion
especially now with such high demand for
technologists chances are very good that
you will be
[Music]
you'll get that phone call back and
you'll be given that interview and
hopefully be able to um
cycle through the whole
process great
um
parshan asks an interesting question
relates to some of the uncertainty in
the economy now but um
he's asking why is it that tech
companies tend to lay off in bulk and
then hire people in bulk
um
do you have a insight into that kind of
dynamic
yeah i do and and you're exactly right
and there's been i mean the thing is
whenever i tell people about that
unemployment rate being 1.7 they're
shocked because they see all the
headlines from the big companies where
google's hiring going through a hiring
freeze microsoft has a hiring freeze
meta might be laying people off oracle
is laying people off i mean there's
there's sort of this chaos
or this perception of chaos at least um
and it also extends to
smaller startups that
like coinbase and so on that were in
very specific industries like fintech
and crypto that are kind of under fire
right now for various reasons that don't
necessarily have anything to do with the
company now
companies
smaller companies and startups hire
exuberantly because a oftentimes they're
on a real rocket of growth and they need
they did they just need bodies and seats
to be able to
keep that growth going so that they can
turn from startup into the next google
or at least they hope so the other thing
too is that that rapid hiring
it needs to be done because they've been
given like the round a or the round b
funding and also because they they need
to demonstrate to the world that they're
on the grid it's also a perception thing
they need to demonstrate that they're on
the growth trajectory in addition to
getting the people to get the work done
um
with larger tech companies it's often a
case of
a they have the money to hire i mean
like when you think that these companies
are taking in 20 30 billion dollars a
quarter you say you simply have the
money to hire that talent and if you
hire highly specialized talent in
cutting edge areas like augmented
reality or ai or whatever it is you get
the talent and the other people don't so
there's sometimes this urge to like
just hire people as fast as you can
we'll figure out a slot for them they're
very smart it'll help um
what that means though is that when
there's periods of economic uncertainty
whether warranted or unwarranted um
startups obviously realize we've hired
too many people you know especially if
the growth starts to slow and then
unfortunately sometimes they need to cut
or at least pare down a little bit in
order to deal with that
it's over exuberance followed by that
and then at the large companies the
large companies are a different case
because
at the fang companies even when they're
supposedly in a downturn i mean everyone
is like oh meta's about to go down in
flames so when you look at meta's
quarterly results they're still making
tens of billions of dollars a year and
there's not really any sign that that's
going to slow down it's totally it's
fine um
but one of the reasons why they tend to
pare people down is they get this
internal sense that they need to be and
you've heard for example the ceo of
google say this they get the sense they
need to be more efficient that somehow
you know now that we've gone to a
certain point now that we've accelerated
higher this point we need to stop and
reevaluate and rethink and tweak and
everything like that um
not so much at
it depends on the fang but like for
example meta is a really good case right
now where their whole dive into the
metaverse is costing them many billions
of dollars a quarter and so a lot of
their cost cutting is related to
they need to pour such enormous
resources into a next generation
initiative that might not pan out for a
decade that they're like sort of taking
another look and making sure that
they're doing things now to put them on
a trajectory for sort of tighter
spreadsheets into the future and that's
where that's coming from um
but one thing i mean if you're just
getting in the tech one of the key
things to realize is that this is
constant i mean people who have been in
the industry a long time from like 2001
through 2008 through whatever
you just have to keep your skills up to
date because it's going to be a roller
coaster at some moments that's just the
way it works
yeah
there's an interesting story
from the the
deep archives of tech history about uh
the guy who founded a
pc company personal computer company
called eagle computer back in the early
1980s
and this was back when that was the big
thing that no one had ever seen before
so
his company went public one day and he
went to a
dealership of ferrari sports cars went
out for a test drive and crashed his car
and unfortunately died and
the company had to
cancel their initial public offering of
stock because
their ceo had just passed away and
ultimately it led to the demise of the
company and
this is one of those things where
irrational exuberance
had an effect on a particular company
but not long after that the the boom of
pc companies went
bust and we followed on with
you know all the other booms and busts
that we've seen in
in the dot
com bubble and
and everything else that's followed so
yeah it is a kind of a roller coaster
industry but
with the last couple of years digital
transformation that's come especially
with as you said remote work and the
nature of
transformed business
it's
less a matter of this is a tech industry
that's separate from other industries
and more this is part of the
economic fabric of the of each world
economy so
um
that that makes it a much more secure
field than it might have been back in
the 80s or the 2000s or whatever
um
are you seeing demanding companies for
it
service management skills
yes it support is one of the in fact let
me drop a
um
so for people who want sort of a tempo
of
kind of what's going on in the tech
industry um obviously and this is a self
plug i mean we at dice at dyson sites we
do lots of data breakdowns and so on but
there's also a site called comptia which
offers a lot of certifications and some
of you may be familiar with it but every
month comptia does an enormous um
i'm going to drop the link in the chat
in a second but
it comptia does an enormous job report
that shows a breakdown of demand for
things like it support but there's
always going to be a need for it support
i'm going to find the link
software engineering is always a job in
demand but for example last month just
to break this down
software developers i.t support
specialists it project managers systems
engineers and network engineers which
you know obviously includes the cloud
and so on um i just dropped that link in
there
are all in demand and when you look at
this they also comptia does a very nice
projection over kind of a longer term of
you know which
which emerging tech such as ai is hiring
and what numbers and so on so that's
that's that's really use if you're not
sure about kind of where your profession
sits uh comptia is always useful um
stack overflow every year publishes a
developer survey they interview an
enormous amount of people i think 90 000
or so on that always gives a
comprehensive breakdown of like which
languages are most in use and which jobs
are sort of paying the most the moment
at dice we have the dice salary report
which churns out similar data every year
we generally release it in the january
february time frame then updated
throughout the year so there's lots of
resources out there to
give you that assurance if you're not
sure if a particular job is sort of
in vogue but the good thing is that like
a lot of tech jobs right now because of
the demand like there's there's a ton of
stuff that is um
employers are really hungry for great
um
we have a couple of questions from the
linkedin audience as well um
that have to do with the non-programming
roles you talked a lot about the the
hard technology
requirements of these companies but what
are they looking for when they're
looking at product managers product
owners digital marketers things like
that
so project management is
at the fang companies project management
is a very huge and complex job and what
they are evaluating for with regard to
project management is the ability to
it's not just
this this is more of kind of a senior
role than anything else but oftentimes
at these companies given the size of the
tech teams you're not managing the
reports directly who are doing the work
you're also you're managing the managers
who then report up into you and so with
project management a lot of the time
you're you're sort of
the the main goal is to build a really
great emotional
rapport and connection with your
managers and sort of make ensure that
you're sort of everyone is communicating
everything is transparent and everything
is seamless because
the job is so complex and there's so
many elements moving around and everyone
needs to have like absolute trust with
each other to get these projects done on
deadline and then obviously iterate
through the inevitable bugs and
everything else
um
that you just these companies need
people with soft skills they need
there's like i said before like there's
no room for brilliant jerks it needs to
be
people who have teamwork empathy
communication transparency and that they
are able to listen
um and sort of anticipate problems as
they come clear and that they can
also empower the people beneath them to
get done what they need to get done
because micromanagement doesn't work
when you're at google or microsoft and
you're running a team of 200 people
trying to build
something for
ios or something like that you need to
be able to
trust that your people are going to get
everything done that they are kind of
the top of what they do um that you've
hired and sort of pulled them onto your
team correctly and then sort of let them
go and then clear the way for them both
in terms of dealing with upper
management also dealing with the outside
world so they can do their best work um
yeah i mean i would essentially for any
sort of non-technical role that's key
same with marketing as well because the
marketing teams also tend to be huge
i know a couple years back for example
apple was still in sort of a
micromanagement standpoint where
everything sort of stemmed down but
there's been a new regime over there too
so it's much more kind of balanced now
from what i've i've heard second hand
it's interesting also because
non-technical roles all have their own
tech stacks
under them in terms of the the sets of
tools that you need to understand and
especially in a tech company you may
need to understand how the
technology development side works in
order to understand your
role as a product manager or
understanding what the product is you're
selling as a marketer and that type of
thing so
um
a lot of these
so-called non-technical roles have a
big technical component in terms of
being able to understand appreciate and
and
especially
feel for the the the technology side as
well as just being able to you know do
things like knowing how to use
salesforce and knowing how to you know
to use uh
jira or something like that for project
management so
um that's correct the just a really
quick insertion to that yeah no jira is
definitely a skill that non-man that
non-technical people will need to know
because that's key to project management
you're also going to have to be if
you're in marketing side of things
you're going to become an seo expert and
that's just because that's the name of
the game these days so tools like
semrush
and so on that allow you to analyze
keywords and everything like that i mean
that's
tools like like kind of very technical
tools like that are are definitely going
to be key unfortunately a lot of them
you know some are more user friendly
than others and i'm not going to drop
any vendor names but you know sort of
mastering them is um going to be key for
those non-technical roles and an
understanding of what you're actually
doing you know which means talking to
technologists and figuring all of that
out
well we've run up on our hour and um
there's just
far more questions than we could
possibly get to so i'm going to
apologize to our audience for
not being able to handle all of their
questions but um
we are going to move on to to close out
um
the
session so let me
get back to
the closing slides that we do have for
you
and
i'm just gonna mention a couple of
things as we
say
thank you to nick but before we go i
want to
we talked about certifications talked
about training skills development i'm
going to give you an example this is one
of the kinds of programs that simply
learn offers
and you'll see the number of the
programs
on our website are branded with our
industry in university partners
one of them is caltech and there's just
a particular example of one of the kinds
of programs that we do which is
um
you know comprehensive
programs take you from
a basic level to
an advanced level in job readiness
um we organize these programs
so you can take individual courses with
us if you want to polish your python
skills or if you want to
explore
certification in
comptia certification we have courses
for for that in various um
uh areas and
cyber security certifications that type
of thing but program of this type is is
one that will take you through a whole
series of skills and it's built
we showed a stair step function where it
takes you through
sets of different skills each one
building to and enabling the next step
until you get to
a capstone project in these kinds of
programs where
you get something in your portfolio that
you get to show to
potential employers and one of the
advantages of our industrial or
university align programs is that you
get access to some of their resources
the
faculty instructors from their programs
as well as uh their alumni association
so
uh we mentioned that because that's the
business simply learn is in and i'm
gonna ask one poll question in the
audience which is what
we showed you one example around cloud
computing but what are the kinds of
skills
each of you are particularly interested
in
acquiring and adding to your
tool set or or defining your career path
so i'll give you about
30 seconds to
take this on and also a key part of this
is the second part of the question which
is
when will you get involved
when do you want to take that next step
is this something that you're planning
to do
right away to
change your career path or
improve your your career trajectory or
is this something that you plan out for
a little farther in the future
give another 10 seconds
and coming up on the time
all right
all results
so
we're seeing a pretty even distribution
across
the different sets of our categories of
skills and
uh really none of them are
standing out as particularly
more or less uh data science
cloud computing ai
and
full stack are all about a third of the
the audience are interested in but
there's a like i said a broad interest
in the other categories as well
and it's good to see also that
about 40 of the people are looking to
get started in that path right away so
um
i will
drop into
the chat
our
link to our website so you can produce
some of those programs that we offered
again i mentioned that we have some free
self-study uh
resources available to you if you're at
a point where you're just looking to to
see what interests you and then we have
uh in-depth programs at the other end of
the spectrum so i want to say thank you
to nick
and
it's been a
really wonderful session i've
seen from the the quality of the
questions that people are extremely
interested in in what you've had to say
today so
appreciate you're helping us with this
yeah thank you everyone's been great the
questions are absolutely wonderful so
yeah good and good luck and wherever you
are in your career right now and it's
it's it's a good time to be in tech okay
here is uh the
linkedin
link put that into the chat
so that you can reach out to nick
and here also is
the link to our website so that you can
reach out to us
and with that
i just want to
remind everyone you can connect to us on
our social channels at simply learn on
facebook and twitter
you can
find us
at simplylearn on linkedin
and we would love to welcome you into uh
our learning community
but um
whatever path you take we wish you
all the very best in your career
and
we wish you every success in the tech
industry so
thank you for being here
you